Namo tassa bhagavato harahato samma-sambuddhassa Namo tassa bhagavato harahato samma-sambuddhassa
Namo Tassa Bhagavato Harahato Samma Sambuddhassa Hommage to the Buddha, the blessed, noble and holy self-enlightened one.
Hommage au Buddha, le noble et bienheureux et illuminé.
J'ai pensé ce soir à faire le côté plus délicat de la méditation.
Il y en a un.
Et ce que je veux faire, c'est unir ensemble les cinq facultés spirituelles et les sept facteurs de l'enlightenment.
Donc, ce que j'aimerais joindre ce soir, c'est les cinq facteurs d'éveil et puis les sept...
Les cinq facultés spirituelles et les sept facteurs d'éveil.
Just to go through them quickly.
Je vais les mentionner rapidement.
There is faith,
la foi, l'effort, l'attention, la concentration et la sagesse.
Les sept facteurs d'éveil sont l'attention, le calme et l'intérêt,
l'effort et la concentration, et l'équanimité et l'investigation du Dharma.
Toutes ces facultés reposent sur la première, SADDHA, qui est le mieux traduit en confiance.
on peut la traduire par la confiance donc la confiance apparaît grâce à son compagnon qu'est la sagesse
Donc premièrement, la confiance s'élève en nous quand nous entendons le Dharma.
Quand nous le recevons.
Il y a quelque chose en nous qui dit « oui, ça c'est vrai, c'est intéressant ».
Et puis nous commençons à y penser, à y réfléchir Jusqu'à ce que cela devienne notre propre compréhension
Et cela aussi augmente notre confiance puisque nous y avons pensé, réfléchi.
Et puis le troisième niveau de confiance, c'est quand nous l'expérimentons à travers l'ipassana.
Donc il y a la connaissance par le fait d'entendre, la connaissance par le fait d'y réfléchir, et puis la connaissance par l'expérience directe par du pensement.
Il faudrait donc l'équilibrer avec le développement du cœur dévotionnel.
Il y a beaucoup d'exercices dans le bouddhisme Theravada pour développer la dévotion.
Très souvent, le bouddhisme Theravada est considéré comme quelque chose de très sec, pratique, intellectuel.
La psychologie.
Mais si vous allez à un pays bouddhiste Theravada, ce qui vous attire, c'est les aspects dévotionnels de Theravada.
Mais par contre, si vous allez dans un pays qui pratique le bouddhisme Theravada, alors vous serez surpris par l'aspect dévotionnel.
Je suis allé une fois dans un centre près de Colombo, très dévotionnel.
Et c'était l'un de leurs jours de lune.
C'était le jour de la pleine lune.
Et au Sri Lanka, c'est un jour de férié pour tout le pays.
Et quand vous rentrez dans le temple, vous voyez plusieurs choses.
Des personnes qui se prosternent.
Qui aspergent avec de l'eau.
Ils offraient des fleurs, offraient de l'incense, allument des bougies.
Tout cela sous ce magnifique arbre de la Bouddhie.
Et ils étaient tous rassemblés autour
Et tout le monde est réuni autour d'eux.
Et donc il y avait le silence à part le murmure des chantings.
Donc l'atmosphère émotionnelle de l'endroit était aussi épaisse que du beurre.
Et je pense que parfois nous manquons des émotions religieuses.
Mais cela apporte en fait la douceur de la vie spirituelle pour nous.
Mais au contraire, ça fait surgir la douceur de la pratique.
Mais bien sûr, tout le monde est différent.
Donc, certaines personnes sont complètement imbues d'argumentations intellectuelles.
Pour d'autres, l'argument intellectuel, la psychologie sont très mouillés et n'éloignent pas ce désir de méditer.
Mais quand nous éloignons une dévotion, cela nous aide souvent à vraiment nous donner à la pratique.
Mais parfois, quand on élève en soi ce désir, cette dévotion, eh bien, ça va nous aider dans la pratique.
Et la manière dont cela est pratiqué dans le Buddhiste Theravada, c'est de contempler sur la vie du Bouddha.
de contempler la beauté du dharma et de contempler la splendeur et la grandeur de ses disciples
Donc en lisant sur la vie du Bouddha, il est possible d'avoir une connexion avec ce Bouddha historique qui a vécu il y a 2500 ans.
Donc il est juste une personne ordinaire, tout comme nous.
Et tout comme la plupart d'entre nous est arrivé à un moment donné à un point.
Et donc apparemment il avait en ce temps tout ce qu'il pouvait désirer.
Il appartenait à une famille riche et puissante.
Il avait une femme, un enfant, un beau cheval, et de très bons serviteurs.
Il a réussi dans sa vie.
Mais quelque chose en lui a produit ce sens de l'inquiétude.
Mais quelque chose en lui a produit ce sentiment de cela n'a pas de sens.
C'est cette inquiétude existentielle, anxiété, peur, angoisse existentielle.
Ceux d'entre vous qui ont lu Jean-Paul Sartre et des gens comme ça,
Ces gens ont compris la souffrance.
Si vous lisez des écrivains comme Jean-Paul Sartre, vous voyez qu'ils ont compris ce que c'était que la souffrance.
Si vous avez lu Beckett, vous savez que Beckett connaissait la souffrance.
Ce qui a sauvé Beckett était son humour.
Ce qui a sauvé Beckett, c'est son humour.
Et d'après Camus, être un être conscient qui souffre consciemment n'avait pas de sens du tout.
Pour lui, la chose la plus digne pour un être humain était de se suicider.
Donc le Bouddha lui-même est arrivé à ce non-sens.
Mais il y avait encore de l'espoir parce qu'il y avait des enseignants à l'extérieur qui disaient qu'il y avait un chemin.
Pour couper une longue histoire, ils se sont déçus.
Et donc, pour rendre une histoire longue, courte, eh bien, ils étaient... Ah, ils l'ont déçu.
Donc, vous pouvez l'imaginer, il était émacié parce qu'il a pratiqué ses pratiques de mortification.
Et il ne voit pas la fin de la souffrance.
Il n'y a pas de chemin vers la fin de la souffrance.
Donc nous pouvons méditer là-dessus.
Voilà un homme qui est arrivé, qui a médité là-dessus et puis qui est arrivé à cette barrière.
Il a fait de grands efforts.
Il a fait de grands efforts et il est arrivé à cet abysse.
Un abysse, pardon.
Un abysse, as well.
And as the story goes, a woman is passing by with a bowl of rice pudding.
Et donc comme le dit l'histoire, vient un jour une femme avec un bol de riz, riz au lait, et en voyant cette pauvre créature, elle lui offre le bol au lieu du Dieu à qui elle allait l'offrir.
Et en voyant cette pauvre créature, au lieu de l'offrir, d'offrir ce bol de riz à son dieu, elle l'offre à Siddhartha.
Et donc vous connaissez tous l'effet salvateur du riz au lait.
Donc cela leur amène à un souvenir dans son enfance où il observait son père en train de faire une cérémonie de la boue.
Oui, l'ouverture de la saison agricole.
C'est la manière de son regard qui ouvre une autre possibilité.
Et donc c'est la manière avec laquelle il regardait qui a ouvert une nouvelle possibilité.
Donc il y avait cette stabilité de l'attention que l'on pourrait nommer l'absorption.
Mais avec cela, il y avait aussi un certain intérêt.
Un certain souhait de connaître.
Et l'image que j'ai à l'esprit, c'est celle d'un jeune enfant.
4, 5, 6 ans.
Et vous savez que quand un enfant voit quelque chose qu'il n'a jamais vu avant, comme un petit insecte, une pétale,
Et donc, vous savez, un enfant, quand il voit quelque chose pour la première fois, comme un petit insecte, si vous regardez leur visage, il est complètement engagé.
Les yeux sont complètement engagés.
La bouche est complètement relaxée et la bouche est ouverte.
Les mâchoires sont complètement détendues et la bouche est ouverte.
Et depuis notre position supérieure d'adulte, nous pensons qu'ils ont l'air stupides.
Et nous les secouons et leur disons, réveille-toi.
Et à ce moment, nous leur empêchons de pratiquer cette intelligence intuitive.
C'est exactement l'esprit auquel nous devons revenir.
Et ça, c'est exactement l'esprit que nous devons redécouvrir.
À part que cette fois-ci, cette intelligence a été entraînée, éduquée.
Donc ce type de réflexion va développer une connexion avec le Bouddha historique.
donc quand nous considérons sa vie complètement dévouée à l'enseignement donc un certain amour surgit en nous pour lui un certain désir qui nous donne envie de suivre ce chemin donc ce que je veux dire c'est que la foi a ces deux parties
Comme je disais, la foi, la confiance a ces deux aspects.
Donc d'un côté l'aspect intellectuel, de la compréhension.
Mais cela peut devenir très très sec si cela n'est pas soutenu avec un cœur dévotionnel.
Et c'est pourquoi dans toutes les religions, vous avez des rituels, des cérémonies.
Donc, c'est la qualité de la confiance.
Maintenant, malheureusement, ce qui peut se passer, c'est que cette confiance s'affaiblit en une confiance.
Malheureusement, ce qui peut se produire, c'est que cette confiance se raidisse en une croyance.
Et ça, c'est exactement ce que le Bouddha ne veut pas que nous fassions.
Parce que la croyance va mettre des oeillères devant vos yeux.
Donc, dans un sens, nous devons investiguer le Dharma de la même position que lui-même a commencé.
Donc, d'une certaine manière, il nous faut investiguer le dharma à partir du même endroit, de la même position que lui a parcouru.
Et ça, c'est la position de ne pas savoir.
Je ne sais pas.
Le Bouddha a dit cela, mais je ne sais pas si c'est vrai pour moi.
Le Bouddha a dit cela, mais je ne sais pas si cela est vrai pour moi.
Nous devons partir de cette position de je ne sais pas, ce n'est pas sûr.
Cette confiance maintenant supporte l'investigation du dharma.
Donc cette confiance va venir soutenir cette investigation du dharma.
Donc l'investigation du dharma et le mot paññā font référence à la même chose.
cela fait référence à ce que nous avons déjà entre nos mains comme sagesse
Mais ça fait aussi référence à ce qui est en nous, cela qui connaît, qui sait, qui peut savoir.
Et c'est cela que nous appelons notre intelligence intuitive.
Cette intelligence intuitive est quelque chose de plus que la pensée.
Et donc cette intelligence intuitive est ce qui est au-delà des pensées.
Et comme je l'ai déjà dit, cela peut souvent se confondre avec les pensées.
C'est pourquoi nous faisons ce grand effort pour entrer dans le corps et réduire la pensée jusqu'au point où la pensée s'arrête.
Cette intelligence, alors qu'elle a fait un insight, a besoin de la pensée pour lui dire ce qu'elle a juste vu.
Donc, cette intelligence doit faire un effort pour réaliser, pour voir.
Ah d'accord.
L'intelligence a besoin de la pensée de manière à se dire à soi-même ce qu'elle sait.
Je suis sûr que vous avez tous eu l'expérience de, par exemple, d'adviser quelqu'un
Donc vous avez tous fait l'expérience de donner un conseil à quelqu'un.
Et vous entendez dire quelque chose de très sage que vous n'avez jamais pensé avant.
Donc ça c'est l'intelligence qui se réveille à sa propre sagesse.
Et qui ne sait pas jusqu'au moment où l'occasion se présente.
Cette intelligence exprime aussi sa compréhension à travers les sentiments.
Et souvent, quand une personne est trop dans les pensées, cela les arrête de vraiment communiquer avec ce qui se passe.
ça l'empêche de communiquer vraiment avec ce qui est en train de se passer et donc parce que la pensée sépare ce qui ne fait pas de sens pour elle
Par contre, quand l'intelligence est plus au niveau du cœur, au niveau du ressenti, il y a ce champ intuitif, cette compréhension intuitive.
Mais des personnes comme cela vont confondre l'intuition avec les émotions, les sentiments.
Mais en réalité, ce sont des chemins pour la communication et l'expression.
De là découlent la philosophie et l'art.
Donc voici le rôle de cette intelligence intuitive, pañña.
Donc au niveau spirituel, il s'agit de voir où se situe l'illusion.
Donc l'illusion est à l'intérieur.
C'est pour cela que c'est si difficile de se libérer.
Parce que c'est ceux qui regardent, c'est ceux-là qui connaissent l'illusion, qui sont dans l'illusion.
Donc c'est ce qui regarde qui est dans l'illusion.
C'est clair ?
Oui.
Par exemple, je vais vous donner un exemple.
Prenez la vue.
Je peux regarder une photo et quelqu'un d'autre peut regarder une photo.
Nous sommes deux personnes et nous regardons les deux la même image.
Mais cette personne-là ne sait pas qu'elle ne voit pas les couleurs.
Et moi, je ne sais pas qu'elle ne voit pas les couleurs.
Donc nous nous disputons à propos des couleurs.
Seulement quand
son visage est découvert pour être coloré, peut-il résoudre l'argument ?
Donc, ce qui s'est passé ici, c'est que cette intelligence est entrée dans ce phénomène psychophysique.
Ce qui s'est produit, c'est que cette intelligence a pénétré ce phénomène psycho-physique.
Souvenez-vous, ça c'est ma phrase préférée, organisme psycho-physique.
Non, non, oui, c'est ça, organisme psycho-physique.
C'est ça.
Et celui-ci a fait l'erreur de penser que c'était la réalité.
Et notre grande illusion, c'est de croire que nous sommes des êtres humains.
Alors, de manière conventionnelle, bien sûr, nous sommes des êtres humains.
Mais malheureusement, en vraiment croyant que c'est ce que nous sommes, nous cherchons notre bonheur à travers cet organisme psychophysique.
Bien sûr, si nous croyons fermement que nous sommes des êtres humains, alors nous allons chercher notre bonheur à travers un organisme psychophysique.
C'est ce qui est d'un point de vue conventionnel comme terminologie.
Mais au niveau spirituel, c'est une grande erreur.
Et donc nous nous sommes transformés en des êtres humains qui souffrent.
C'est une évolution.
Maintenant, nous devons revenir en arrière dans cette évolution.
Nous devons dévolver pour retrouver notre être originel.
Et ça, c'est le but de Vipassana.
Et pour faire cela, nous avons besoin de certaines qualités.
Les premières sont ce mélange entre l'effort et la concentration.
Donc nous devons faire attention ici parce que quand nous parlons de concentration, il y a cette tendance à se crisper.
Ça nous rappelle trop l'école, ce genre de choses.
Alors que la concentration est en fait un état de relaxation.
Alors qu'en réalité, la concentration, c'est un état de relaxation.
C'est quand l'attention est juste sur un objet, elle peut rester sur cet objet.
C'est pour cela que nous utilisons la respiration, c'est pour stabiliser le processus de l'attention.
Et dans les Écritures, ils utilisent ce mot « ekagata » qui signifie « aller dans une direction ».
Donc l'esprit va dans une seule direction, comme un rayon laser.
Et l'effort est là pour soutenir cette concentration.
Mais à partir du moment où le mauvais effort entre en jeu, alors l'agitation surgit.
Et l'effort est là quand nous essayons d'achever quelque chose.
L'effort mauvais, c'est quand nous essayons d'obtenir quelque chose, de réaliser.
Donc, réaliser quelque chose ou bien l'obtenir.
Si l'énergie tombe, alors cette esprit qui va d'une façon à l'autre, disparaît en inconscience.
Donc, si l'énergie baisse, alors cette énergie de concentration va se dissiper.
C'est pour cela que si nous voulons nous endormir, alors nous allons focaliser notre esprit sur une seule chose, comme la respiration ou bien l'amour merveilleux.
Donc vous pouvez faire la différence entre une personne qui est endormie ou quelqu'un qui est vraiment très profondément concentré.
Donc le méditant qui s'endort, il fera ce mouvement d'aller se fracasser la tête sur le sol.
Mais la personne qui est dans un état de concentration, mais elle est juste descendue, enfin le niveau de concentration est un peu baissé.
Elle pourrait être assise dans cette posture bien érigée.
L'énergie est un peu abaissée.
Elles sont complètement assises comme ça.
Alors même le niveau d'énergie est un petit peu baissé, mais il est quand même assis dans cette posture érigée.
Et de l'extérieur, nous allons dire, mais quel méditant extraordinaire.
Mais en réalité, rien ne se passe.
Et malheureusement, dans certaines traditions, vous pouvez trouver que ce blackout est considéré comme une sorte d'attainement spirituel.
Mais dans certaines traditions, ce blackout va être considéré comme un niveau avancé de concentration.
Il y a une jolie histoire de la tradition hindoue où un sadhu demande à quelqu'un de lui apporter de l'eau.
Il s'est ensuite mis en méditation et est tombé dans l'un de ces états.
Dix ans plus tard, il s'est réveillé.
Et ses premières mots étaient « Où est l'eau ?
» Même dans l'industrie, ils vous disent que ce n'est pas worth while.
Et même dans la tradition hindoue, ils vous disent, cela n'en vaut pas la peine.
Et aussi, Saint-Jean de la Croix dit que ces états mentaux ne valent pas la peine.
Donc, l'énergie doit soutenir la concentration.
L'énergie se corrompt si vous commencez à atteindre quelque chose.
Si cela corrompt, si cela veut obtenir quelque chose, si un certain désir d'accomplir quelque chose entre dans la méditation, cela le rend restreint.
Par contre, si cet effort est teinté de désir, alors à ce moment-là, cela va corrompre la méditation.
Si l'énergie tombe dans la paresse, alors vous tombez, vous vous endormez.
Maintenant, je reviendrai à l'effort correct dans une minute.
Donc, je vais revenir à l'effort juste dans un petit moment.
Donc, l'autre paire, c'est le calme et puis l'intérêt.
Donc, à ce niveau-là, nous sommes au niveau du cœur.
Maintenant, vous verrez le mot « pitié » traduit comme « joie ».
Donc vous verrez le mot piti traduit comme la joie.
Mais il est utilisé de bien des manières différentes dans les enseignements du Bouddha.
Mais ici, il s'agit de la joie de l'investigation du dharma.
Et ça, c'est la joie de l'intérêt.
C'est l'intérêt qui empêche un scientifique ou un philosophe à vouloir savoir.
Et si il n'y a pas de calme, cela aussi devient excitant.
Et s'il n'y a pas le calme, alors cela aussi devient excité.
Mais par contre, s'il y a trop de calme, alors à nouveau, nous nous endormons.
Donc, il y a toujours, il faut trouver cet équilibre.
Maintenant, je dirais à vous que si vous cherchez quelque chose pour empêcher votre méditation,
Le meilleur de ces sept facteurs est l'intérêt.
Si vous travaillez avec les maîtres et les enseignants burmés, vous verrez qu'ils poussent la concentration.
Et si vous travaillez avec les enseignants birmans, vous verrez qu'ils vont surtout mettre l'accent sur la concentration.
L'effort et la concentration.
Donc si vous travaillez avec eux, faites attention qu'ils ne poussent pas trop au point où vous effondrez.
Je pense que cela a trait à une différence culturelle.
Souvenez-vous que les climats tropicaux vont plutôt amener les gens vers la paix.
vers le repos.
Et pour cette raison, l'enseignant a besoin de pousser.
Mais ici, en Occident, nous avons assez de gens qui nous poussent.
Mais assez poussés.
Donc notre boulot, c'est de se détendre.
Donc c'est amener cette énergie...
Et pour amener dans la pratique de la méditation cette belle énergie d'intérêt.
Oui, par exemple, ici nous sommes en train d'observer la respiration.
Et ce terrible bourdon s'éteint.
Et puis l'ennui terrible surgit.
Et parce que nous sommes remplis d'intérêt, et au moment où l'ennui apparaît, nous pouvons dire « Ah, ça c'est intéressant !
»
Donc, l'intérêt vous fera toujours vous tourner vers quelque chose avec délice.
Et donc, si nous sommes vraiment animés par cet intérêt pour connaître notre propre psychologie, vous êtes vraiment « empowered ».
Et souvenez-vous, personne d'autre que vous n'aura de l'intérêt pour votre psychologie.
Les dernières paires sont l'équanimité et l'investigation du Dharma.
Ici nous commençons à comprendre l'importance de la qualité de l'équanimité.
Et là, nous commençons à comprendre l'importance de l'équanimité.
Parce que cela nous ramène à la confiance dont nous avons parlé tout à l'heure.
Et donc ça fait référence à la confiance de sorte à ne pas tomber dans les croyances.
Donc l'équanimité signifie l'ouverture.
Donc à partir d'une position sans préjudice.
Sans préjugé, sans aversion.
Sans peur.
Hum ?
Et à partir de cette position, nous sommes très ouverts.
Et quand quelque chose en nous surgit que nous trouvons effrayant, nous devons réétablir cette équanimité.
Nous devons ré-établir l'équanimité.
Et nous pouvons faire cela en portant notre attention sur une partie neutre du corps et attendre jusqu'à ce que la stabilité revienne.
Et puis ensuite revenir sur ce qui est en train de surgir, émerger en nous.
Donc l'équanimité nous aide à expérimenter les choses directement.
Mais ce qui est également important, c'est de pouvoir investiguer le Dharma.
Parce que nous venons de la position de ne pas savoir.
Parce que nous venons d'une position de nous ne savons pas.
Nous ne sommes pas sûrs.
Donc, quand nous parlons d'investiguer le Dharma, nous parlons des trois caractéristiques d'existence.
Donc ces trois caractéristiques, l'impermanence, l'insatisfaction et le non-soi, c'est là que gît l'illusion.
C'est en pénétrant ces trois caractéristiques que nous pouvons défaire l'illusion.
Et c'est ça notre travail.
Et toutes les autres techniques de méditation sont là pour nous aider à investiguer ces trois caractéristiques.
Lorsque nous pénétrons vraiment à l'intérieur de l'impermanence, nous entrons dans un contentement absolu avec le monde.
Nous acceptons les choses comme elles surgissent et comme elles disparaissent.
Et parce que nous savons qu'elles passent, nous ne nous y attachons pas.
Et puis nous venons au débat du Bouddha,
et puis nous venons aux déclarations du Bouddha, rien au monde ne vaut la peine que l'on s'y attache.
Quand nous pénétrons à l'intérieur de dukkha, de la souffrance,
nous voyons, ce dont je vais parler demain, le processus de désirer et d'identifier.
Et quand nous pénétrions le cause du souffrance, le désir,
Et lorsque nous pénétrons à l'intérieur de la cause de la souffrance, le désir, et donc ce désir basé sur une fausse compréhension disparaît, donc ce n'est plus possible de créer de la souffrance pour nous-mêmes.
C'est juste pas possible.
Et lorsque nous comprenons le non-soi, cela coupe toute fausse relation avec cet organisme psychophysique.
Et c'est ce que nous appelons le état de Nibbana.
Et c'est cela que nous appelons l'état de Nibbana.
Quand nous parlons de ces facultés spirituelles et des facteurs d'éveil, cela peut sembler très compliqué.
Cela peut paraître très compliqué.
Je vais commencer à me faire du souci pendant la méditation.
Est-ce que mon effort est juste ?
Est-ce que je devrais être plus intéressé ?
Est-ce que je suis assez calme ?
Qu'est-ce que je devrais voir ?
Et cela va détruire tout espoir de libération.
Donc le Bouddha a mis ça très clairement, très simple.
Et en réalité, je me demande pourquoi j'ai parlé de ça.
Il pointe out that when right awareness is established,
Donc il souligne que quand l'attention juste est là, ces facultés vont surgir tout naturellement pour la soutenir.
Et nous n'avons pas besoin de nous soucier de ces qualités-là.
Nous pouvons même les oublier.
Donc nous devons juste revenir à cette attention juste.
Et comment est-ce qu'il décrit l'attention juste ?
En termes de l'objet, ce dont nous sommes conscients, il est très clair.
Et donc, en termes d'objet, quand il décrit l'attention, il est très clair par rapport à ça.
Quand il s'agit de l'objet dont nous devons être attentifs, il est très clair par rapport à ça.
Et vous pouvez lire cela dans le discours de comment établir l'attention juste.
Donc, très simplement, c'est le corps avec ses actions, donc à la fois la respiration et les actions du quotidien.
tous les ressentis qui viennent du corps ou de l'esprit tous les états mentaux que nous expérimentons et toujours cette investigation de ses enseignements mais
Mais cela ne nous aide pas à comprendre ce qu'est l'attention juste.
Et je crois qu'il nous explique cela très clairement au début de ce discours.
Il y a toujours trois mots qui apparaissent en même temps.
Atapi, Sampojano, Satima.
donc avec l'effort juste, l'intelligence intuitive est le fait d'être attentif donc de manière générale cela veut dire être attentif c'est l'attention pure
donc l'attention est placée sur l'objet de manière à voir l'une de ces trois caractéristiques
Donc en premier, il parle juste de la respiration.
Donc premièrement, nous rentrons en contact avec la respiration, nous la ressentons.
Et puis ensuite, nous calmons l'esprit, nous calmons le corps sur la respiration.
Et puis nous commençons à voir la nature impermanente de la respiration.
Et donc nous continuons d'observer jusqu'à ce qu'il y ait suffisamment d'intelligence intuitive et puis d'attention juste.
Jusqu'à ce que la vision profonde apparaisse.
C'est tout ce que nous faisons.
Quand nous observons la respiration, nous notons le « V » baissé.
Cela maintient l'intellect heureux.
Mais notre attention est sur les sensations du « V » baissé.
Et nous notons que la respiration s'élève, disparaît, s'abaisse, disparaît.
Et au fur et à mesure que nous nous concentrons davantage sur ce processus, à un moment donné, l'intellect, les pensées s'arrêtent.
Et à ce moment, il n'y a que cette intelligence pure qui connaît qui sait les choses telles qu'elles sont.
C'est le processus.
Et donc, la pratique que nous faisons est là pour développer ces sept facteurs.
Même dans la vie de tous les jours, quand nous faisons quelque chose d'ordinaire, cette intelligence est primée.
cette intelligence est développée donc la vision profonde peut arriver à n'importe quel moment quand les conditions sont réunies donc notre travail c'est de développer cette attention juste et c'est suffisant
Si vous vouliez contenir tous les enseignements du Bouddha en un seul mot, je pense que vous choisiriez le mot sati, l'attention.
Je peux seulement espérer que mes mots aient été d'une certaine aide.
Je peux juste espérer que mes mots ont été d'un secours.
Puissiez-vous être libérés de toute souffrance.
Tôt plutôt que tard.